brandon judd president of the national
border patrol council brandon this is
the worst possible scenario playing out
52 people that were coming into the
united states apprehended in panama with
ties to terrorism but the big question
how many people weren't apprehended with
those ties to terrorism
well and that's the problem is this is
the worst case scenario because we just
don't know the number of people that are
that are getting away and when you
consider
that that many people have already been
spotted in another country with ties to
terrorism and then you look at the
number of people that are crossing our
borders from countries like russia
romania armenia uzbekistan
gambia senegal
you know these these countries generally
tend to have animosity towards the
united states and they're coming into
the united states but then you look at
the number of godaways and the people
that we that have been able to cross our
borders illegally and just have gone
undetected or detected or were able to
get a get away
500 000 people when you continue
consider the 42 000 that were able to
get away in the month of september so we
just don't know what's coming across the
border and that is scary and it needs to
be a point of emphasis for this
administration in order to protect the
american public but they just don't seem
to have the will to do what is necessary
to secure our borders to make it safe
for the citizens of this country 500 got
away godaways you say we know that there
are hundreds of miles of stretches of
border that aren't being patrolled
because those border patrol agents are
busy processing people
52 people with
ties to terrorism that were trying to
enter the country would you call this a
national security crisis
it is and it always has been when you
look at what we deal with and what we
face on a daily basis and regardless of
whether you consider it just people from
countries of special interests or
countries that want to do us harm when
you look at the drugs on top of that as
well this has always been a national
security interest and it needs to be
something that is looked at very very
hard in order for us to get this under
control but it's not rocket science and
that's what so up um frustrating and
upsetting to those the men and women
that put on the uniform and go out and
patrol the border is we know
that this has we've been able to get the
border under control before and we can
do it again and it doesn't take a whole
lot as long as we have the policy in
place to allow us to to take those
people in custody and remove them
immediately if we don't do that if we
can continue to reward people for
crossing borders illegally we're going
to see numbers that are just
astronomical that we just can't deal
with yeah and congressman gonzalez the
sound bite that we played at the top he
said that when he spoke to the foreign
minister in panama he asked her does
anybody in the biden administration know
that a hundred thousand people are
coming or headed to the united states
and 52 with ties to terrorism that were
apprehended and she said that she's
trying to contact somebody in the biden
administration but she can't get a hold
of anybody how is that an acceptable
response from the administration
it's not especially when you consider
that we had the the single largest
illegal immigration event just last
month um that played out in front of
everybody on on national television it
doesn't matter what media you looked at
it was there and then when you consider
that that 234-mile stretch of border
that del rio covers um we just didn't
have anybody out there because they were
all under that bridge trying to handle
that that chaotic situation um it's just
what we see every day and that's this
that's a fault of this administration
president biden's pick to lead cbp chris
magnus his confirmation hearing was
yesterday and we learned
that in 2007 there was a lawsuit filed
against him from several
black police officers and they claim
that he made some racist jokes and
stopped them from getting promotions a
jury found him innocent but what do you
make of this situation
well i think it's very curious that the
far left as long as you're a
conservative if you have any allegations
against you whatsoever the far left will
condemn you um
including the base that the
administration relies upon yet if it's
somebody that's an activist if it's if
it's somebody that that believes in in
being activism even if you have a
uniform on they'll forgive you and
that's what they've done in in the case
of of magnus which which again is so
hypocritical um of the far left and when
you deal with politics and you put that
into law enforcement it just doesn't
belong um and again it's something that
we have to deal with and we just can't
get a handle on it right now you know
brandon magnus was also asked about the
images of border patrol agents and they
were accused they were falsely accused
of whipping migrants and he's called
those images troubling but he says that
the investigation needs to play out do
you have an update on that investigation
no we don't and it's gone way past what
the administration said is going to go
past but the reason is is because there
just isn't anything wrong so they have
to un they have to overturn every single
stone to try to find something wrong
when when president biden said that
those agents will pay and that's a quote
they're obviously the investigators are
obviously going to have to come up with
something that's the reason why it's
taking so long all right brandon judd
thank you so much for joining us this
morning really important topic great to
have your take on it thanks
thank you